Hello Freak bitches fruit.
That's why I'm.
That's why I'm the champ because I
survived that.
This overcoming,
it'd be like,
you know what?
I lost a hundred 60 pounds.
Look at me.
You're a great.
What gave me champ?
And you're 44,
45,
45 in a week or two and people are
ducking you like crazy.
Interesting.
David Haye said he was all in software.
I'm sorry,
I curse.
Curse away.
Let's go chat.
David Haye was all in at one point,
so not too many left hooks.
So pissed.
Yeah.
What happened?
I went over to England,
which I love with my uk.
Had went over there just to fuck with
him till he got an apartment again.
That's the field that's the field.
Like honestly,
I was down and now Chambliss listen so
many days,
you know,
I was like,
man,
you know what?
I'm trying to think man.
And no one's giving me a shot.
And I'm like,
you know what man,
maybe I should get a job and shit.
I'm like,
Nah,
you know what?
Then I woke up one day and guess what?
Snoop Dogg said,
let's go champ.
He's smoking weed.
I'm fucking with you.
Let's go champ champ.
That was the night before.
I was like,
Bro,
the night before was like,
Yo bro,
you really try and champion have fights
man,
and maybe it's never going to happen for
you.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
Yo.
And then I woke up like four or five in
the morning.
Snoop Dogg was saying,
let's go champ,
champ back.
Beautiful.
What?
You've done some crazy shit too though,
man.
Like,
uh,
like especially with the Klitschko
Biscuit,
if I had a lot of fun,
fun videos though,
showing up,
drinking his water,
fucking with him.
He knocked him over when you were
writing,
I gotta jump.
Well,
how long ago was the paddleboard
incident?
And I don't even know.
I lost track of time champ.
I was like two years maybe.
But he just,
you couldn't get a fight with him?
Nah,
he saw.
I've been listening.
I've been chasing clicks.
Go honesty since like 2005 was supposed
to fight him,
like posts to fight.
He fought in New York City.
So was a fight.
Uh,
Shannon breaks,
everything was set to go and he wind up
fighting a calvin brock who's from North
Carolina.
No one could.
I couldn't understand it where we had,
you know,
we literally had a contract.
Yeah,
it was.
It was going to sell out a lot of fans
with all crazy all the time.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I'm bringing that.
Come on.
He didn't want it because he was
dangerous and that's what I'm going
through right now.
They can say what they want about me.
Joe Desena thorough.
He's crazy.
He's this.
But guess what?
I'm dangerous.
I've got tons of emails.
I'm not a snitch.
Listen,
I got tons of emails of guys with their
manager saying,
no,
not right now.
He's too dangerous.
I've got deontay wilder backed out of a
fight with me for $2,000,000.
He can't front.
I got emails and everything.
Let's go chat.
I'm getting excited as you can tell,
but once you,
once you started calling him the champ,
champ,
the meters,
Roger,
now man,
we told you about what I want to talk
about fights.
Let's go.
Let's go champ.
Champ.
And Joe Rogan Klitschko one was
particularly hilarious because he was on
that paddle board.
There's nothing more humiliating getting
knocked over fight.
People are talking shit and he's still
wanting to fight me.
He still wouldn't fight me right here.
Look at him.
First of all,
what is he doing out there?
Board by himself and stupid in the
middle of nowhere.
I mean,
this is almost like a setup Wednesday.
Does he?
Yeah,
he does this every Wednesday.
I got mine at the coast or somewhere.
Where's that?
It's Miami Fort Lauderdale.
Hollywood champs.
Shout out to Hollywood,
Florida.
Best sound in the world.
Does he live down there?
Yeah,
he lived down there.
I lived down there.
We all lived down there.
So he would stay on that paddle board.
Go out in the middle of the ocean.
It'd be pat.
I need this document.
Waller and he would just be paddling
around exercise.
But a weird exercise.
Yeah.
He said where?
The strange guy.
Yeah,
he's weird.
That's how the beef started.
Joe.
Chris,
shout out to Chris Lawrence to have you
with factory.
Who's the greatest guy on earth?
Honestly,
like it wasn't for him,
you know,
this guy put the fuel,
put the cash behind me.
I was flat on my face.
This guy came and was like,
you know,
I believe you.
I was fat the press.
He seen me in fresh market.
He was like,
Damn.
I was like,
you know,
he seen me.
I came back like seven,
eight months later I came to his office.
I was like,
Yo,
what's up?
He was like,
Damn.
He called me a week later.
It was like,
Yo,
we should do something.
I was like,
let's go champ.
And uh,
here we are today.
You know what I'm saying?
I've been traveling.
The world thinks is Chris and I'm now.
I've actually been ordered.
The WBA has ordered a fight between me
and Lucas Brown and hopefully we can
make that happen.
I was seeing something on your instagram
that it's,
it's still not signed yet though.
You're disappointed.
Very disappointed.
Look as brown trying to avoid it or what
is your,
you know what?
You know what Joel?
Honestly,
like I've been through so much the last
couple of years,
wilder with Klitschko,
with a different funding with hae a
door,
hangs on the car and I went over to
England,
shout out to the UK.
I love it.
My second home,
it was big,
a big fuel injection,
uh,
behind what I'm doing right now because
I went over there and I've never felt
that type of love anywhere in the world.
Like for myself to go where,
you know,
we speak the same language,
we speak their language and um,
just to have the love man,
it's just incredible.
Everywhere I go,
let's go champ,
you know,
it's just amazing,
man.
That really put a lot into what I'm
doing right now.
But he decided to go over there and get
an apartment.
I had to,
I had to because I was flat on my ass
champ.
And I was like,
you know,
trying to move up in the rankings.
I gave everybody a call out haymon every
labella,
everybody,
the cubists I gave everybody that call
was like,
Yo,
I'm trying to get back in the game.
Nobody believed in me.
Chris Lawrence called me and was like,
Yo,
I believe in you,
and that's what I was like,
you know what Chris?
He said,
Yo,
you a little crazy.
I said,
I am a big diagnosis,
a little crazy.
I suffer from PTSD.
This is true,
you know,
sad.
But um,
what I'm exciting and I'm gonna make it
happen because I'm a believer that
nothing could stop me chatting.
We look at me,
nothing can stop me.
I don't care who you get.
Whoever say they can beat me,
they lying because when we put the,
when the Bell Ring Champ,
I'm a whole different person because I'm
charged.
Look at me.
Look what I've been through.
Look what I'm telling you.
You can hear the emotion in my voice.
The pain still.
Lil Champ.
I man,
let's go champ.
I'm in.
Let's go champ.
Let's go chat.
I don't understand why it's so hard to
get you fight.
So this is I'm dangerous champion.
Look at me.
Look at me and I'm crazy.
I believe that I'm here.
I was a promoter care.
I don't care who I fight.
They can say what they are also not
stupid.
I'm not gonna fight fights for me.
For guys,
for pennies.
That's meaningless.
That's gonna.
Beat me up.
I'm 44.
I'll be 45.
I already got it,
but so much limit on his body.
I'm a heavyweight.
I fought George Foreman Champ.
I fought fatality clinico champ for
free,
by the way,
and we'll talk about that later for no
money.
I fought France while both the dre
mercer.
You feel me?
I fought some big punches.
George Foreman.
So for me,
I'm not gone.
Go down.
I'm not gonna.
Fight every guy out there just to try to
build myself.
I'm a former two time heavyweight
champion the world.
That alone should get me a title.
Fight.
That alone,
that's how it used to be.
Gods have come out of retirement from
the,
from the beginning,
from Sullivan days and came out of no,
no fights and got a title fight.
What drives me crazy is your so
marketable.
That's what drives me crazy.
The are in the UFC.
No,
no.
The best ever.
They would be lining up first few left
and right.
If you were in the UFC,
listen,
champ.
I know,
I know.
That's my boy now.
That's another story in itself.
Nineteen 90 for three or four.
Maya,
which is his name,
right?
Marilyn.
He sold the UFC to Dana and them,
right?
Yeah.
In Two thousand one call rob right now
he tell you who is boy Shannon Briggs.
He was sitting on the couch with me
waiting for Mark Roberts.
Took them home to talk to try to get
mark to get to,
uh,
go in with him with the UFC champ champ.
Sitting on the couch with me.
Ra or boxing is hard to get fights lined
up because there's so many different
conflicting promoters and different,
you know,
their piece of the Pie.
And then it's hard to get fires to agree
to fight someone like you who's
dangerous because I'm,
you know,
I'm fast,
I'm a punch hard and I got a chance.
So you know,
they only count on one thing that I run
out of gas.
And I say this all the time,
champ,
if you'll,
if your biggest asset is hoping on the.
I run out of guys.
You fucked up my leg where?
I apologize.
Boys and girls.
Don't apologize.
Apology messed up.
Excuse me.
I apologize.
Boys and girls,
you messed up if your own.
If you relying on on me running out of
gas.
That's your.
You're going into a fight.
Took my man.
I just hope you run out of gas.
You already lost tramp.
Yeah.